[Music]
welcome back to Hannity you may remember
last night I address the roiling more
issue at the end of the program I
decided to do it again at the end of the
program tonight to be consistent in
terms of where we put it in a program
it's important three more women have
today come forward making accusations
against Senate candidate judge Roy Moore
now clearly this now raises new issues
in the state of Alabama things are
getting worse and now very tough on the
voters of Alabama I live there I'll talk
about that in a second last night on
this broadcast I demanded answers from
Judge Moore when the judges story broke
just to remind you I lay it out of
history I don't rush the judgment and I
said these allegations are so serious
this should all transcend politics sadly
it's not but it should I'm never going
to apologize for not rushing to judgment
the issue of presumption of innocence is
important all of us however these
allegations are beyond disturbing and
serious I have a 16 year old daughter
Ivanka Trump said something today there
is a special place in hell for people
who prey on children Ivanka Trump is
right there is a special place in hell
for present predators that is something
every one should agree with that should
not be political
now with judge Moore unlike everyone
else in the media I went right to the
source I interviewed him I went through
the Washington Post allegations
methodically point by point through each
and every allegation in the Washington
Post in that piece and I let him respond
shockingly for the first time in my life
even liberals praised that interview
rarity for me and for me and so many
others it is because what happened in
that interview it did raise new
questions and then came the issue of the
yearbook that allegedly shows judge
Moore's message to one of his accusers
and that is why for the sake of the
people of Alabama last night I demanded
answers they deserve them those people
Alabama deserved them before an election
and today we got the answers to the
questions that we asked let me give you
a judge Roy Moore's attorney did a press
conference and questioned the validity
of the yearbooks signature he said it
could be forged and demanded a forensic
analysis well I spoke to a forensic
analyst on my radio show today and he
said they
we'll be able to tell if the ink is
fresh or not and they will be able to
look at comparisons to his handwriting
then and then that yearbook and
determine if it was his judge more today
late tonight
released a letter to me let me read it
to you I'm gonna read it in full I think
that's fair
dear Shawn I'm suffering the same
treatment other Republicans have had to
endure a month prior to the general
election for US Senate in Alabama I have
been attacked by the Washington Post and
other liberal media in a desperate
attempt to smear my character and defeat
my campaign over the last 40 years I've
held several public offices including
Deputy District Attorney
Circuit Judge Chief Justice of the
Alabama Supreme Court in addition to
running five statewide and three County
campaigns for public office I have been
involved in two major controversies that
attracted national attention one about
the 10 commandments the other about the
sanctity of marriage the Alabama
judicial inquiry Commission Court of the
judiciary and the Attorney General have
investigated scrutinized examined and
vetted me not to mention every opposing
candidate against whom I have run I've
been married for almost 33 years to my
wife Kayla and we have four children
five granddaughters we are in the
process of investigating these false
allegations to determine their origin
motivation for instance we have
documented that the most recent accuser
Beverly Nelson was a party in a divorce
action before me in a toois County
Circuit Court in 1999 no motion was made
for me to recuse in her accusations
Nelson did not mention that I was the
judge assigned to her divorce case in
1999 a matter that apparently caused her
no distress at a time that was 18 years
closer to the alleged assault he had 18
years later while talking before the
cameras about to suppose it is salt she
seemingly could not contain her emotions
my signature on the order of dismissal
in the divorce case was annotated with
the letters D and a da representing the
initials of my court assistant curiously
the suppose a yearbook inscription is
also followed by the same initials da
but at the time I was a deputy district
attorney not a district attorney
attorney those initials as well as the
date under the signature block and the
printed name
restaurant are written in a style
inconsistent with the rest of the
yearbook inscription the sevens in
Christmas 1977 are in a noticeably
different script than the sevens in the
date 1220 to 77 I believe tampering has
occurred we at a stage in American
politics in which false allegations can
overcome a public record of 40 years
Stampede the media and politicians to
condemn an innocent man and potentially
impact the outcome of an election of
national importance when allegations of
events occurring 40 years ago and never
before mention during a 40-year career
of public service are brought out and
taken seriously only 30 days before a
critical election we may be in trouble
as a country he then goes on I adamantly
denied the allegations of Lee Kaufmann
and Beverly Nelson did not date underage
girls and have taken steps to begin a
civil action for defamation because of
that at the discretion of counsel I
cannot comment further Roy Moore now we
demand sitt demanded rightly answers
from Judge Moore he provided them to the
specific questions we asked in my
opinion so serious the people of Alabama
they need to know the truth and they've
got to have all the facts that they need
and that means that the Alabama voters
can make an educated informed inclusive
decision for their state when they go to
the polls and if that means whatever it
means to get to the truth of it means
more time I believe the governor
according to Gregg Jarrett has the
ability to make that decision
the Alabama people deserve that Gregg
Jarrett said the governor can delay the
race if need be now the people of
Alabama deserve to have a fair choice
especially in light of the new
allegations tonight now we have told you
everyone's point of view
the accusers continue to have an open
invitation to come on this show and
share their story at the end of the day
I want to tell you something I lived in
Alabama I enjoyed my time in Alabama and
I know these people they're smart
they're great Americans God family faith
country and I am very confident that
when everything comes out they will make
the best decision for their state
shouldn't be decided by me
by people on television by Mitch
McConnell Washington talk show host news
people
one more thing there's a report by the
way of sexual misconduct in Congress I'm
demanding tonight they paid 15 million
dollars your money that was paid out to
victims who are they tell us now and why
did they pay it they need to be exposed
we'll have more on this tomorrow night
Lauren